but then if you live in this country
maybe you don't mock so much because
seattle which is a city in our country
has just entered a law that required
people to wear helmets while riding
bikes now that's good there shouldn't be
a law about that dude if you want it's
the reason they ended that law that
jason rants will explain to us tonight
jason is our man in the pacific
northwest he's got the story for us hey
jason
hey welcome to another edition of
everything is racist this time it's
bicycle helmet laws that are racist
because black bicyclists were given
tickets at a disproportionate rate than
white bicyclists now this claim is
originally based on a non-peer-reviewed
report by a woke phd student over at the
university of washington this was an
attempt to tie bicycle infractions to
instances of racist policing so across
the city of seattle and king county as a
whole it's a 30 ticket if you're not
wearing a helmet while riding your bike
but after the first couple years pretty
much wasn't enforced and yet the king
county board of health decided to look
into the ticket distribution as part of
their commitment to what they define as
equity because they were inspired by the
blm movement so this report says black
bicyclists are ticketed nearly four
times more than white bicyclists for not
wearing a helmet but the data represents
under 300 total tickets two black cycle
has given out over 13 years
and some of the people who were ticketed
were homeless most likely riding stolen
bikes which likely caught the attention
of the cop at the moment that they gave
out this ticket nevertheless it was
enough for the whole king county board
of health by a vote of 11 to 2 to repeal
the law because they say the research
that i just cited shows that quote
racist and discriminatory enforcement
came as a result of that except the
research doesn't actually show that it
disproportionately targeted anybody it
doesn't say why the numbers are what
they are it also doesn't say that whites
aren't wearing helmets but getting a
pass for it they make up the majority of
the tickets all the data shows is that
black bicyclists in seattle just happen
to not wear helmets as much as the white
bicyclists that's all it shows whites
were ticketed by the way 10 times more
often than asian writers so if this was
intended to be some sort of racist law
it wasn't very good at it to your point
go ahead and oppose this law for
legitimate reasons wanting to focus on
personal responsibility i think that is
a legitimate argument but the logic here
is absurd so apply it in this way the
majority of gang members in the state of
washington are black and latino so that
means arrests associated with gang
violence will disproportionately impact
blacks and latinos so should we get rid
of enforcement should we stop going
after the drive-by shooters because of
that no of course not it is absurd
but new york city does that some ph.d
students should do a study on why all
the self-hatred in the pacific northwest
it's a bottomless well of it it'd be
interesting to know what that's about
okay jason rants great to see you
tonight thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else